I'm George Lewis case professor of music
at the Columbia University right here
and before we begin I just wanted to
express my great appreciation to my true
love's for being here
to speak about this morning and also for
that extraordinary film which is in fact
I found out two films in one because the
performance of the poem Woodson which
which at least two of us ran our pocket
and myself have been 98 for performance
here come and the topic of our
discussion of one of the topics of my
discussion follows directly from the
whole section of the film in that we
wanted to look along other things a bit
more closely at the central role played
by my tremulous and fostering
innovations and music technologies not
only as a composer but also as a sort of
an institution builder with its founding
in 1975 of the Institute for Research
and coordination
acoustic music or simply air come now
you some of you may know that for
example canonical new media histories
tend to date the advent of interactivity
and art making to the mid 1980s but if
you remember the period when multimedia
didn't refer to computers you may find
that a bit ironic there's a bit of
historical rupture separating the notion
of interactivity that we know today from
the practice that arose in the computer
music communities beginning at this time
the early 1970s and repol and other
pieces by master blue letters are signal
examples of this pioneering activity in
new media interactivity for example
report and I think of that in the minds
of many of us as a major work to emerge
from that early period and it's
something of a tribute to the
integration of technologies or everyday
lives that the brief segment from the
piece didn't say anything about the way
the technology was developed
and there's a lot more to say about that
but before I do I just wanted to for the
sake of the people listening later on wk
CR to introduce the members of the panel
first professor to my right professor
Miller pocket who won Putnam and NSF
fellowships to study mathematics at MIT
and Harvard he finished his PhD in 1986
at the same time around the same time
from 79 to 86 professor Puckett worked
on real-time techniques for live music
performance at the MIT Media Lab and
then he joined aircon where he wrote the
very important computing program max the
highly influential environment used by a
computer musicians in the world over and
which was as you might have seen on a
part of the screen you saw it was a
little screen segments those are
basically max things those are back
screens yes I'm in 1994 professor
joined the faculty at the University of
California San Diego where I was at the
time as well and where he is now
professor and chair of the department of
music and is developing a new software
environment for computing music called
pure data then we have Martin cher
singer to my left associate professor of
media culture and communication at New
York University specializing in sound
studies musical culture media and
politics of the 20th and 21st centuries
with particular interests in non-western
music the political hermeneutics of
absolute music cultures and musicology
philosophy and music theory all relation
to political economy in an international
frame professorship senior recently
prevented the paper Beulah's profit or
how'd Elizabeth understands music at the
annual meeting of the American music
illogical Society in November of 2010
then we have the person who's made this
all possible many respect from the
standpoint of working with the
Department of Music and we like to also
thank Shani Pierre or you phone you call
her sunny right said yes Chani Pierre
who's the director the Maison Francaise
Fabien is assistant professor of
composition Columbia University
professor levy studied compositional
Girardi's a music analysis with me
lemme nasus ethnomusicology with Sheila
toad and orchestration with Marc Andre
Davi he holds a PhD in musicology from
the occult azoty to LCL sociale a
master's degree in mathematical
economics as well his compositions have
been performed across Europe Asia Africa
and America he has received numerous
prizes a professor levy was an aircon
from 1998 to 2001 first as directed of
the project studio online that has
pedagogical on advisor and he's also
published two edited volumes under here
comes Mark now for my part I'm not going
to go through a long yeah except to say
that I was at here calm for three years
between 1982 and 1984 85 and in 84 I
presented a work for Network interactive
computers in their well-known solid the
projects show so and that was around the
time that I heard the parents version of
her poem now you know you were quoted as
saying maestro that I think at one point
you said something like and this is the
English translation we try to force see
certain directions that the music could
take and give them a chance to manifest
themselves now certainly we can see that
in the frame of composition but it seems
that the foundation of ear comm had a
great deal to do with assembling a
cultural consensus that went beyond
music making could you speak about the
origins on that
and satisfied to be the present
situation and then when you are not
satisfied with the present situation you
try to find a solution that's the case
generally what music was in the hands
did not work seriously and therefore the
results were very disappointing most of
the time it was poetic with all the
inconvenience and convenience but
especially inconvenience of wait it
seems like that and I think I submit a
very serious work has to be done on the
material of music and thinking of music
you know I was always in that direction
in front of the architects because the
the architecture began to began to
change not only the realisation that the
conception of architecture when people
where we see with the Batchelor like the
architecture and then with steel glass
and so on all these materials you can do
something totally unexpected
it began with based on the or and now
you know
it has evolution between miss one day
one day you see all the evolution of the
bacteria itself and I think music should
have also the same reflection on the
material music how is the Sun what is
the sound exactly how one can use the
sound and perception and so forth invent
music with not only it is forbidden to
do seems positively with the new
material which applies but how did it
work in terms of the cultural consensus
the political consensus for example
we've all read in various investors that
you met personally with the President of
the Republic Georges Pompidou at the
time too
that's it you know whoa she's fast and I
don't want to think about the pain here
I was inviting a country house in the in
France it's 69 and said the deer came a
corner of the president-elect and
excellent it was a joke and I say please
could you come back because I'm not sure
my agenda there was the second code the
president would like to have dinner with
you
well I was very surprised and poppy to
explain to me the center he wanted to
have for the Arts and they say there is
no section for music I would like you to
be
the softball the future center for the
yard and so I said yes but you know it
should not be simply a kind of
last-minute sinky it should be a very
important part and then you say well
give me your IDs and I will I will think
about it and so I saw that this time of
your pages I was included in the
development of some for me too as part
of the department's it was a departments
operating as you know it was a painting
department for design
they were Department for recharger and
there was a department for music and the
Department of Music was for exactly like
the other departments the second
province was given to that and this is a
matter of fact because what we do want
to provoke the creation of new things
generally the museum has the tendency to
be a museum with a gallery exhibition
that say see she was not the center of
and yoga was the center of all creation
of acceptance direction and education
report and that was was well while you
were here in the US we are eighth
thinking about the sort of combination
of the scientific technological and the
creative compositional at that time were
you because you had already been doing
these kinds of projects as you said and
you move along with people like
Stockhausen there was the whole history
there there was the entry of the demand
music hall there was the grm but it
seems to me that a certain point there
were whether any prior models for ear
comm that you could always big
institutions like a dancer and if they
are budget restrictions the dancer was
the first one to suffer
therefore I mean for instance there when
the radio is in Germany we are much less
rich and less money then the music
studio was the first in the old
institutions you know that's something
expensive which was not spectacular and
then therefore put the public's music
and therefore I mean it was no study
institution they were always depending
for something because it goes to this
point well you know I have an
experiential that made specializations
that I mean the importance in account
for this foundation that the budget was
depending upon to the centre pompidou
not about the Ministry of Culture
only
you say overture it was depending from
the center security well we have sort of
three generations of people who have
been associated with your comb actually
on the panel I'd like to open it up to
four other people to ask questions that
this is a golden opportunity so shall I
started um I let me tell you it feels
very odds sitting here I joined it here
calm at the age of 26 and of course the
name Pierre Boulez would make people
tremble in their boots not because the
movie made clear not because bullets
would go around chewing people out but
because the quality of the example that
he said was such that no one really felt
like they could measure up to what they
were what they had right in front of
them and another observation I'd like to
make is that in the movie again I heard
it presented that well basically there
was no choice there's no choice but to
learn how to conduct because otherwise
the music wouldn't be conducted there
was no choice but to make your comp
because there was no deer calm and of
course there was a choice you could
Stockhausen didn't do these things piers
got his hands dirty and got involved in
every aspect of making the music of his
time not just composing but but playing
conducting organizing seeing to it that
the computer could actually be realized
as a musical instrument and I think this
is closely related to the fact that
Tara's music is just
at a level of beauty that exceeds that
of most of his contemporaries the fact
that his his mind in his hands were in
the music gave gives the music itself a
kind of richness and animal just playing
sensuousness that that that you don't
get much of in the second half of the
20th century so I'd like to throw that
out there as a comment and maybe a
compliment I hope it's a compliment or
an observation that I'd love for you to
comment on it's this one thing that I've
seen one thing I think I learned from my
days at aircon which were very young
days for me was the importance of was
the importance of the of music as a
performed medium not as a as a studio
medium and what I mean by that is that
if you see a performance of a poem you
you see the music being made in front of
you even though the music is electronic
and that's that's technically a very
hard thing to accomplish and most
electronic music of that era and and
even more even to a greater extent most
of the electronic music that we hear
today is made in studios using a
computer but far away from a stage far
away from an audience and and in boluses
own writings one sees oh that's that's
recording technology recording has been
you know the art of recording has been
elevated as a as a sort of a form of
music making and yet the the thing that
the thing that excited I think Karen
certainly excited me was the notion of
electronic music is a thing that you
made in front of people at the same time
as people heard it and I'm wondering if
if I got that distinction right and do
you did you see this as an imperative
that or did you see it as an imperative
to protect the role of live performance
in the making of electronic music and to
and to make that be a viable way of
making music as opposed to the
Studios centered approaches that the
radio studios were undertaking at the
same time that here comes started why
doesn't that was I remember they were
discussions at the beginning very vivid
disgusted as I mean about the goal of
the account because they have people
were you know wanted to create a world
for itself but in studio and I say no we
must have you know I suffered myself as
a performance of that because I was
following what composers were doing and
I remember us I mean once it was when I
was at the head of the BBC Symphony we
had music which was to be therefore in
parallel with the tape and I remember in
one of this work I have maybe more than
seven cues
miss Matthews and I was conducting
school and looking if I am my I was
ahead of cube wonderful Street behind
the cube 104 salmon that you are totally
paralyzed because you are trying to be
in phase also exactly synchronize with
the tape exist you are always you know
trying to cope with either you are too
late or you are ahead and there is no
gesturing and what you can do every
night against for instance if you have
an insulation kind of atomic limit our
installation we'll find sense you know
initiation which is modified
you can have ventilation I am NOT
against it but if you want to have a
word play there must be some say
something which is life and we do we
take
and their parts I mean by day I remember
I had to fight for that to have to have
like electronics and you wear one of
those most active in the speed and I
remember when you work especially with
venereal proposal as a team that's also
one of the problems you have been in
situation like that but you have people
working together because the musician
has the ID is purchased but he does not
have to realize them
and also that the contrary society
because some IDs that he does not know
how to translate them in kind of musical
terms musician can take these ideas and
transform them as music music
either way mainly society because his
and the you have to have a junction
between the two and that's very
difficult
but you know I asked
I certainly feel like a beneficiary
yes first I want to say how for young
couples our master policies importance I
think people don't realize that in the
history of music there were I think
nobody who was so complete and so a
model in different ways for young
composer first when you study
composition you will a lot of texts by
mr. Buddha's theoretical text on
Stravinsky and there you learn his new
language technique all my students today
have assignments with cognitive
occasions and he's of course modern in
term of musicianship is I think one of
the tests conducted on the world and the
tradition of Stravinsky division like
right incredible he's of course one of
his an incredible composer with
beautiful music and some sin which is
very music maestro bubl's organized is
an organizer he created a lot of
institutions
osmoter born you can still survive who
still bring a lot of things to the music
so when you are in young couples are you
you live with the in heritage of my
school days it's also very first thing
to see that even if people don't know
the name of rickety by you and starts
and know the name of my school as my
school s is a contemporary music is the
one who encountered reflection and music
and
not a spectrum music so my questions
would be that first I want to add two
other aspects which were very important
for me as a young composer first time
this is the sense you had for the detail
you are demanding person but this
humidity which comes with us I was
always very appealed by this sort of
humble man that you are behind the music
and I tried to teach at my teens a sense
of the details a sense of visitorship
you have to have music first so second
thing which wasn't so matter for me was
you mentioned that in the field this
refusal of the primatology that there is
no French music American music and
people said but you want to travel you
have to be yourself and you are always
to go for them
so my question will be this one you are
33 years old younger than Stravinsky and
however people realize how different
something happens with you what strands
I have the chance to be exactly 43 years
younger than you however I see to there
that's many young composers tips we do
count up our music we use technologies
which are little bit different but we
use max/msp real time we use complete
music we have some techniques which are
quite different people use models new
techniques atella but the music remains
kotake music and also for the audience
people think ok this is the control
music that my school has created in
successes
how do you see this evolution today in
2010 the audience today and the young
young composers how do you see evolution
of music because you made this big
revolution do you think it will continue
music now it depends another dollar
generations of a million robots in their
hands and I cannot I don't want to make
prediction because you know to go to a
marginal position I tried to the
institution I created well not for me
because I was always very independent
I'm my life as you know as I mean was in
different countries at different moments
and I was already developed from the
institution right I could go from one to
another one
well I I want to change and therefore I
mean I taught me one thing if you are
sentient centering and an institution
about human even this person being
Williams I report the examples at by
topic
and then that's why I'm in this
institution if if I have created these
institutions I don't want that when I
disappear myself they disappear also I
want they'll remain isolated they can
transport themselves they can be
different on a different level they can
be the different direction we can be
more complex or what they want but they
will not depend on if I am there and
that's an extension if you are too
precise in your inference that was for
me always very important rule that I
observe and therefore you know India can
move after the years of established here
come I even waited I was very active
even in the administration well my
really you know we sometimes I sometimes
your sessions about if the workers we
clean the house we can be imagined
myself and in this position listening to
hours on the strike of the people who
clean the house this was not to be
exciting but I mean I was there as you
know and so the house was solidly
implanted in the bigger house so when I
asked for enlargement of the account
because they were up studios you know I
could speak because I immediately when
they we had Michigan but solid and the
Commerce solidly established like the
Kaaba was solidly established can I say
that I observe I can by give my opinion
but I don't think that here and
therefore this and these institutions
are totally independent of me I I can
give some concept
either one or the other one but I'm not
interfering and I find that simple
people in charge should have their own
opinion
they won't method and their own way
therefore I think well talking about
never being wrong or precise enough to
be wrong my reflection here is going to
be on police's impact and influence on
intellectual non-musical videos
sometimes in the history of philosophy
for example in the case of shop and how
I figured like Beethoven looms very
large or for Kierkegaard someone like
Mozart or perhaps we can argue for
Nietzsche vogner this is a kind of
legacy that has befallen Beulah's as
well equally and we can pick out more
than just one philosopher perhaps most
importantly Delors use de leurs and I
pick him out because of his relevance to
many disciplines today such as
anthropology Media Studies musicology
this sort of resurgence of Delors is
relevance today and what I want to just
reflect on acknowledge today is the
impact and the extent to which Beulah's
is thinking on musical matters and also
his compositional technique have taken
up residency in these different
philosophical Miller's and what is
fascinating is that this has been an
ongoing and ever-changing kind of saga
we can begin for example almost anywhere
in his career his ethnological
reflections associations with unemployed
chef Nev and others the mathematical
dimension the use that Adorno would find
for a philosophy of dialectics and then
perhaps more pertinently for us today
the involvement in structuralism and and
then even more recently in post
structuralism structuralism we can point
to various sort of crucial debates we
might say some of them quite
Michael when levy stars in the raw and
the cooked picks up on a cereal
technique and argues against that find
certain contradictions in it certain non
language like aspects Nicolas Rivera
will do the same with a cereal technique
and then this is answered in turn by
others like people serve and more more
in a more developed way by Umberto Eco
who will argue that it is precisely
cereal technique that opens up the
possibility of understanding a first
articulatory structure as being much
more flexible than it might have been
hitherto understood that language itself
has a kind of articulatory structure
that is more flexible than was
understood by lvi-strauss
and Nicolas reveille once again levy
stars turning to Beulah's as a technique
in a way to rearticulate what language
in general might might mean more
recently the involvement with Foucault
which is to some extent a little bit
hyperbolic because it was published in
English in this country but also Liotta
and particularly Delors they were
encounters that happened 1978 that air
cam which was a very well attended event
in which Beulah's de leurs Foucault and
Holland baths find themselves in the
same room discussing various topics and
dillards perhaps the most enthusiastic
writes a paper about making audible
forces or making inaudible forces
audible and so on and then he writes an
essay again along a similar topic about
time Beulah's Proust and time in which
he talks about non pulsed and pulsed
time and so on and uses in particular
bullets concept of the smooth and the
striated which comes out of pencil la
musique showed we to develop a theory a
philosophical kind of way of thinking
identity outside of or thinking
individuation without identity these
kind of concepts are difficult to talk
about in the context of this sort of
event but essentially moving away from
understandings of identity and very
into repetition and difference and so on
and so forth so reflecting on this and
of course we don't expect any kind of
definitive answer but there's also the
sense in which a there's that these
kinds of developments are reflected in
some of your lexicon over the years so
we we think perhaps of the essay on
taste that was published in Terrell 1963
or the intermittent appearance of words
like the virtual or difference in your
more recent work so for example the
essay we mentioned now about material
about understanding the material in
order to facilitate an idea you use in
that essay an example from orchestration
that this understanding of the technical
and social and historical and acoustic
and so on scientific dimensions of
orchestration should not be out of the
reach of any composer not that you need
to literally know all of this but that
it should not be out of the reach of any
composer and in that sense you use the
word virtual to describe that it doesn't
seem structurally that important for
that essay but there is this subtle
inflection of perhaps in that case a
delusional concept back into ricocheting
back from dollars into your writing so I
was wondering if you could reflect for
us and again no definitive answer is
required but on some of these
relationships
mother language that says therefore
that's difficult for me to give an
answer but I can as well say that I was
amazed myself by some correspondence
especially with literacy what you do
perform very simple things I've seen how
we transform them to really very very
long range concepts occupy occupy in
several times
yes you know what he did about that
because I saw that about reason simply
done for me that was a very practical
see although it has consequences
Alex but I will explain how it came to
be and then you know you see that he has
transformed it completely my simple so
when I was writing a piece infla for
more cooper instrument and the hesitant
instruments and I like the resonant this
woman but I say what can I do with these
roses
I like the celerity and I need paste the
structure of the piece on this kind of
society but how to make a difference
what is the difference between the other
sounds and this sound of Ezra but you
don't influence them they die simply and
then I more or less happy be the
vibraphone die
five four seconds the low register of a
piano dies in 25 seconds and the
mandolin or the guitar dies in two
seconds and so on so you don't touch it
continue and then assuming you don't try
to score with rhythm you unite the
school with just the dynamic and the
register of this one and then you wait
until enough and you go further and
that's what I call the tongue nice
smooth because that has a consequence as
we don't give the estimation of the fact
that's likely you would have you know
something better kind of piece of metal
and you cannot estimate the weight so
you are there
and then you have this this time which
is absolutely not measurable and then on
the cottony if I want to measure the
time then I had to measure it with the
units and even unit or even units that's
not the problem
you know this one is scheming time as
well as me
that's not the problem of style of
difference indeed there is measurement
of the time and then that's I mean the
the perception is totally different and
for instance you know if you have fifty
fifty second fifty beats let's say and
51 beats you cannot make any difference
if you have 50 beats and but the
difference is because you have you can
measure the time and all the piece is
established about measured time and not
measured time and that he gave me and he
took that you know the kind of
difference between measure and non
measure it took doesn't develop that
much beyond what I had such tests of it
because myself being not a philosopher I
think always in practical terms
that is one example but I mean I have
many other examples like that like it
superimposed I'm quite sure I have a
working on it well when you have
different groups and they have the same
time unit but this time unit interrupted
by seeing which are there is very quick
and that's different in each group so
they have the same time you need they
never for inside and I would write that
that was that would be absolutely
impossible because you have to to have
eight appearances between regular and
irregular and then I mean these
categories also belong to the same
category so that's my point of view you
know I think of categories like that and
I let the feel feel yourself speak their
own language benefit for me but I would
unable to find it myself I think of
Matthews and then I received lessons
well I hope that before we conclude
because we are on the clock we have time
for a few questions and I hope you have
a way of giving people microphones do we
have such a thing is there anything like
that here or because is there is there
is okay so that I guess we will please
feel free to be records raise your hand
and be recognized and yes please you're
the first
hello hi my question is from mr. Poole
has some of your writings and statements
earlier that I've read seem to propose a
antagonistic relationship with the past
the certain statements about defacing
the Mona Lisa for instance and sort of
trying to capture a revolutionary
constant revolutionary spirit and which
or Dorner talks about this as being the
the search for the new and sort of
maintaining this constant reinvention
and I was wondering if throughout your
career as you've been able to witness
many changes in the 20th and 21st
century whether you see that the old
order has been replaced with something
new and if so how do you there's a sort
of paradox or contradiction between the
idea of maintaining a revolutionary
spirit in which in which there's a
constant need for reinvention well at
the same time establishing institutions
which which you have which require a
certain level of stability I wondered
how you sort of saw this contradiction
playing out between sort of replacing
old orders with new orders and then what
if the new orders become too stable and
then there's a stagnant within that
just wear people clothes outside and I
am NOT of these institutions there must
be you know a threshold if you have two
people who work together that's not a
sin you should certainly not but that
cannot be a focus it is simply two
people working together or working close
together the cautery if you have 50
people or 60 people who were in the same
not the same connection but in the same
institution when you have discussion I
don't say that in city an institution is
necessarily an institution with which
was before no and it situation for
instance that's the academy lucerne for
a week yeah it was the abstract tell you
ten days on the that's an institution
and there are many forms of institutions
and there are some in some sometimes
services enough to be constant and some
institution to be just for certain
amount of time and the difficulties with
institution that's to survive its own
reputation because after a while you
know there is a tendency to to be very
happy with oneself and say we are we are
the
no you have to put always that under
scrutiny and sometimes say no no no no
it cannot go this way and you have to be
more active you you have to sink more
you have to in you give me your ideas we
will look at that as I mean the
institution is valid in my opinion only
if it puts itself under scrutiny every
day and you know that's like the Phoenix
it has to be burned every day to be
River reborn otherwise you know after a
while it becomes a kind of routine
institution and that's the worst time of
Si and we don't replace we don't want to
meet place within institutions by all TV
institutions okay so for me that you
know I am very careful and I was the
American senators I mean you know I was
always inspecting and looking to see
what happens simply that and if nothing
happens well you see nothing happens
please just see more thank you stuff
happened yeah my question is actually
really similar but maybe slightly
broader first of all I really respect
your music and all the work you've done
for a new music in general um I think in
this day and age and this social
cultural climate at least for me it's
very difficult to believe in any sort of
Tyria logical progress of music
especially western music and you know it
seems more it seems to me that we're
kind of doomed to to continue to or
blessed to continue to repeat repeat you
know music over and over again I was
just wondering if your concept of
musical history has has changed
throughout the years and you know what
if your thought has evolved
and in that regard at all sorry that
wasn't very clear I don't care for this
history of music understand you because
I can always for the present the history
of music will be told by people who live
maybe 50 years hundred years later and
that I cannot predict how they will look
at that you know I look at my my own
vision between 45 and now in 45 I
discovered composers we are not who we
are not at or perform at this time
especially in France we were discovering
they showed that school we were
discovering Bartha who were discovering
powers worth discovering
stop in ski even sunny ski was not very
often perform at least I'm good I have
the impression that we discovered the
revolution of 1914 but they take because
all the works which are really very
revolutionary of nineteen between 1910
and 1920 let's say so we discovered
revolution and we discovered the
establishment but now for instance when
I look at this past I say well that
history and I could not say in 45 it was
part of history I did not know what was
any important I hesitate between the
should be our thirty one understand back
sixteen if you follow what
what to say after sixteen was really
discovery opposite 31 in establishment
but I see now and I could not see it
in 1945 certainly not and their forts I
mean you know even negative words as I
prayed you know there are discussion now
it was a revolutionary NDP at the
beginning and conservative the second
half of his life
no I can I can imagine that's the first
that's you know there was a danger in
the first part of his life to be a man
arrest this danger he felt and then he
turns out he looked at models of the
classics and therefore the trio with all
the first work in this direction and it
was very highly criticized this period
now that we are not well distance we I
say well he avoided with this kind of
seeking of okay classicist he avoided
batteries and it was very important but
thirty years ago I could not save this
way and therefore our thinking the
mystery depends of what we are at the
moment when you judge the history and
there is no way no other way for
somebody creative especially to look at
history that could destroy this concept
which is fixed on history they are
things I have never changed I admire
very much this Levinsky of the but I
must say that the equinox is only the
you know which is totally absurd in a
way that's I mean but that's my opinion
and I don't like to be too important so
maybe somebody in 30 years will find
that 80% was a kind of beginning of
conceiving that we have time for a half
of a last question what you think you
have a long question um if you wouldn't
mind deferring to this long question
even though you have the microphone
Thank You maestro bouleris
I had a discussion recently with
somebody from here come and he said he
doesn't like the concept of work in
progress and then I asked him how do you
think about the idea of pierre boulez of
Ehrlichman and over the SA and over in
variations and I quoted him the phrase
of Adorno and Gustav Mahler that malice
symphony are variations of a lost
original
so is there a difference between every
in progress which he didn't like and
your concept and unfortunately I didn't
see your show it's allure of Ervil
MA and over si was beginning to the end
nothing without I think I was oriented
in this direction everything was
centered and what you where you have to
movement for instance I had to have very
precisely established on the degrees of
the scale and
they're also a form ABA which was the
very beloved by a romanticism especially
the German Romanticism and so and so
forth
I mean you have frames of action now you
don't have any free collection when you
begin a work you cannot say I'm gonna
like this another for me to begin with
just elements and these elements bring
you somewhere where you don't expect to
be even and I have not a theory that
through meant to be your name but to be
well but I have a feeling always that if
I investigate the elements I have in
front of me I will go somewhere where I
did not what I was not sure to go and
therefore as I mean in this world if I
look at that that's a kind of continuity
of segments and therefore as I mean the
work is there can be never it's finished
but it's finished deploying and I can
imagine sent some of my works which are
finished theoretically but I can
maybe 10 years later as I say well I did
not think of that I will suppose that I
will change a life that's absolutely
legitimate that work is not from me
finished never even the work which are I
can say that finished last year in the
loo when you were speaking about that I
suppose with executors small eggs in the
exposition well and for me that's a very
important that I cannot consider the
fragment as another where the fragment
is part of I think that by way of
conclusion I wanted to synthesize a
phrase from Martin searching his elegant
essay speaking of boluses embrace of a
technical promise of electro-acoustic
machine is eloquently expanded to a
philosophical trope in Mille Plateau now
figured as an abstract machine as it is
with Beulah's is synthesizing machine
the abstract machine opens philosophical
thought to concrete new forms it de
territory Eliza's strata to generate a
plane of consistency or a body without
organs and somehow I think this fits
with something that you wrote maestro
Beulah's
in your acceptance speaks for the 2009
Kyoto Prize this is a phrase that stuck
with me for quite a long time after our
wonderful graduate student your sake
oniy she provided for us if I dare to
use only one word to sum up what I
consider essential in this relationship
between the direct and the technology it
would be transgression to transgress is
to extend the limits of our instrumental
technology the construction of the
instrument and its
use two transgressive to go toward a new
world if not entirely new at least
uncommon this is the exception that has
become the rule thank you very much for
speaking with us today